boa tarde
vocês sabem que eu não não tenho o
hábito de andar sozinho
isso não significa que vocês vejam as
pessoas com quem eu ando escolho cada
dia com quem eu vou andar
hoje vocês não vêm mas tá ali sentado no
senhor ele era era um grande samba nosso
camarada bola acaba dos escritores
angolanos
o nome do original que a mãe de nível
era michel labão nós em alcunhados de
michel na barra e aqui moeda
eu vim aqui contrário duas outras
histórias
a primeira história tem a ver com ele um
dia estava com inicio enchê la bamba e
ele disse eu estou entrevistando
escritores sobre as palavras de cada um
as vossas palavras acho que eu não
entendo que são criação original vossa
eu peço que vocês multipliquem e a
palavra que ele queria que lula
explicasse entre outras
eles mas é coisa rápida uma definição
támbém explicar algumas das minhas eu
invento poucas palavras o mia outros
tinham mais coisas pra explicar até que
ele disse é para quem estuda aqui no bom
dia camaradas esta palavra instiga a
investigar
eu disse olha nós embora quando temos
esse determinado tipo de assuntos
o senhor vai ter um patrocinador e ele
fez um complemento directo patrocinar o
que a patrocinar natural patrocina
alguma coisa alcoólica que eu não vou
beber eu não vou beber sumo de laranja
ela foi buscar a garrafa sentamos lado
na sala do hotel
estivemos não estou em erro cerca de uma
hora
agora comecei com a minha definição
pessoal instiga e ele queria saber mais
mais mais ea coisa curiosa que é o fim
daquela conversa e de alguns anos eu não
sabia que sabia algumas coisas não
muitas sobre as antigas com a vantagem e
vantagem de uma pessoa que estuda uma
coisa que também fez e que também era
isso logicamente pode ser complicado
pode ser uma vantagem porque você vem de
dentro e pode ser um problema não vi
problema nenhum vou fingir que não vi o
que eu vejo nas tinga é um lugar da
criatividade pra nós deduzo eu quando
pensamos instiga estamos a ver as
crianças as crianças
entrevistei algumas pessoas sobre isso
que a antiga mas tinha essa coisa que as
crianças fazem sempre às crianças uma
coisa como se fosse periférica e menor
discordo não acho nem prefere que nem
menor
é verdade que castiga é praticada por
crianças e chega uma altura entre os 10
12 que a criança vai abandonando dessa
prática e passa a achar piada as outras
crianças mas como alguns de vocês sabem
a uma altura a nossa vida que isso é
muito sério
eu vivo só chorarem por causa deste ano
houve pressões faltarem às aulas por
causa disto eu próprio cheguei a ter
subterfúgios a fingir que estava com
diarréia não sei com medo segunda-feira
6 telhado castiga do ponto de vista do
jogo claro como você sabe a antiga que é
equivalente aos verbos a investigar
acusar não mexi ghilas eu vou dizer isso
não me instiga ontem estava a dançar
assim fui muito xingado ou seja chega
saiu da categoria de coisa o jogo pára
verbo
nós aqui não fazemos outra coisa mesmo
quando não falamos no vestiário eu
percebo que a minha família é um perigo
viajar com a minha família estamos num
sítio passa um senhor eu estou com a
minha mãe e passa uma pessoa assim como
a calça esquisita mas até isso faz parte
da antiga não é por mal até algum
defeito físico
outro dia estava no sítio passou o
senhor em contramão ele vinha pra cá
tudo feito física está nem vinha na sua
proporção naquela eu olhei desse meu
deus obrigado porque a minha mãe não
está aqui porque sabia mais diversas
aquilo ia fazer um simples comentário
três palavras 4 porque que esse
dispositivo vai despoletar em mim ou
nela e quando a pessoa não pode rir
quando ri mais
epá branco fizeram xixi fizeram xixi no
intervalo agora também a pedagoga da
escola diz que me ama joão da barra
trabalhou andrade silva durante o
projeto e saber jogar com 94 ea mulher
cambojana de pizza vai tocar encontrava
na cabine foi metralhada por confiar
canta só para tocar de lado esquerdo da
área chutou quando fica nervoso bikila
perto um gringo do topo vai pagar 70 e
nos tocando aumentar quando tá bem
nervosas atira no lixo não foi
contemplada com praia
olha o michel michel tahi também tá aqui
conosco este homem
michela barra com as suas perguntas
convidamos a uma vez olha já para ir á a
sorbonne com que fica lá nas europas em
paris para dar uma conferência sobre as
tiga seu vice michel vandamme eu não vem
só organiza coisa e tal
uma semana de turismo já preparar hoje
está aqui naquelas universidades já que
estudos em lisboa está aqui a sorbonne
mas estava a usar eles não já preparei
você não tenha preparado nada comecei a
pensar a pensar não inventei estes
esquemas que é muito simples é tão
simples que nós não vemos rapidamente
aos instigadores que são 21 provoca o
outro começa a antiga automaticamente
escola rua nossa casa uma festa
juntas aqui uma maravilha é assim uns
que vai
esses primeiros são os agitadores três
aqui quatro né porque o agitador fácil é
muito interessante porque o ditador tem
um projeto um projeto duplo ele é agitar
o outro que ele não está a apoiar ela a
evitar fazer jet lemas de sua linda
fazer linda tabela
ao mesmo tempo ele também agita o amigo
dele não é para acalmar isso não é boxe
pra ficar aqui a passar um lenço ele
agita também ou só pra gastar gastar
gastar acabou já não tem instiga o
agitador tac ao naturalmente nem tem
espaço físico para 4
eu tô aqui a instigar não aguento mais
esperar chamorro trago um agitador
entrar para investigador e eventualmente
quem está aqui na assistência aos mais
calmos que tem medo tão sozinha recorde
está a 1 que tem vontade já está a
agitar um caso mais atos tás aqui tás a
ver essa da assistência que o time está
mais neto também vem quando a torcida tá
bom então ver você chama
então às vezes acontece que dá
assistência
bom isto são quadros la paz o amor não
interessa o menino jesus é uma coisa que
eu que andei a pensar mais teoricamente
que era a questão da motivação é pai por
mais que eu eu entrevistei muitos mil de
gravar em muitas sessões com humilde e
toma anti tempo para chegar à falaram
sobre as coisas naturalmente e não haja
a mínima dúvida que a motivação da
antiga é ridicularizar o outro
claro que tem o formato a mãe do pai
juan a mais sempre mais delicados né
investiga turma a turma do hematoma é
demais não
o mai não começa amanhã é as palmas não
estava plantado as formas mas há uma
coisa muito bonita na antiga e que é
natural
não sei se vocês lembram disso eu lembro
na minha rua antes do tempo das damas e
das suas etapas
a pessoa que tenha mais prestígio na rua
eo que chegava a mãe é porque há pouco
mais bonito porque tem a cabeça não sei
que isso não era assim 85 ou vocês tiga
você ficar calado
ontem saiu a sorte fui estudando fui
estudando estudo conteúdos formatos das
antigas vocês fui vendo que havia esta
questão da normalmente passa pela casa e
é óbvio a maneira de ofender o outro é
pegar ou em características físicas
pessoais ou em tudo que lhe cercam
por isso é que vai pra mãe pai irmã
condições da casa
lembro de uma liga muito forte estava
2009 várias mas essa tava 2010 chegar e
ele diz outro vai mandar mais uma roupa
deixar a irmã da primeira mão da segunda
pré nome acima de olha parecia o caso
aqui do mundial o cristiano ronaldo
quando vai fazer a falta olhou assim
disse tomar influenciam na [ __ ] d'água
vejam quantas palavras têm esta antiga
tua mãe envelheceu na [ __ ] d'água
vocês são capazes de imaginar quantas
histórias estão nessa frase estamos a
falar
[ __ ] d'água não estamos a falar de uma
casa que abre a torneira
estamos a falar de envelhecer na [ __ ]
d'água
a promessa do que não chegou o tempo que
aquele bairro não tem água não você está
rindo mas eu entendo por que eu quero
dizer é entre si na final
por isso é que eu aponto que castiga tem
os seus conteúdos que a gente pode ouvir
quase como uma nota quem não conhece
muito no princípio também já vim fazer
isso não tem graça nenhuma
também o primeiro objetivo principal ter
graça bom pelos vistos em e não tem
alguma graça e quando o formato próprio
formato da antiga é feito conteúdo ou
seja não é o que está a ser dito não é
bicho d'água é por exemplo o que eu
quero dizer o formato é toda a
performance
às vezes a performance normalmente é
curto mas tinga mais longa é muito
arriscada sei quanto mas tinga longa que
já está tipo história chega o fim
ninguém riu o vai embora vai embora
porque não é muito arriscado mastiga
longa e aquelas diga que acabava sempre
e musicalidade já não era o conteúdo já
não era o que estava a ser dito
lembro me de uma quebra qualquer coisa
sempre usar com o pessoal que vem do
interior para luanda luanda
nunca tinha vindo obina diante eu nunca
tinha visto tanta eo a terra estava em
um bom o que tinha visto é a performance
eo havaiano acaba em música desenvolve
uma coisa fantástica nas crianças a
memória por castigo é a acumulação é o
vinil desligarem meia hora sem parar a
esta velocidade está humilde só a dizer
150 siga 200 chagas mas há um momento em
que a memória acaba não tendo o chip de
32 gigabytes aqui e começa a pagar nos
restos do que acabou de se lembrar do
que
outro disse que começa uma criação
simultânea isto devia ser estudado do
ponto de vista neurológico porque eu
desconfio o sistema lhe começa a criar a
simultaneamente com a realidade é uma
pressão muito grande a gestão 40 50
pessoas aqui e você tem que criar não
pode falhar a expectativa dos amigos que
estão ali
ganhar ou perder é relativo é o público
do filme na realidade não é o público eu
vi um miúdo que chegava muito e chegava
chegava chegava e outro estava com menos
tiga e fez a mesma coisa boa que
reservou a última a falar eu tava ali
uma manhã há muitas aguentar disse não
agüentar mais uma
ele deu a segunda e agora acabei
sentindo um acabou dá mais uma bola eu
me aguentar as duas três e da terceira
bom criou uma expectativa maluca ficou
todo mundo assim eu também com gravadora
nem com medo que o árbitro sem saber
quem ia consertar o outro olho espera
espera disse sua mãe tem trecho do meio
da fé
em relação à minuta era era o time era o
time
o que ele fez foi criar um espaço de
silêncio e jogou o último trunfo que ele
tenha até agora aconteceu isto as
pessoas ficaram a rir
o outro não conseguia falar porque na na
na na na sua mãe tem trecho chega fora
fora fora e perdeu mesmo o resumo eu
acho que dava poder e prestígio no grupo
começava com a rua e eventualmente com a
escola coloca uma vez levei a lata um
rapaz que dizia que ele era o rei o rei
das antigas rei mesmo já tive geral
luanda a feira do bairro dele e portanto
estudar da criança por um lado isso por
outro lado a compensação de outras
características mas o mais baixinho dos
óculos o mais gordo chinho que tem que
se defender não é chega uma altura é
ameaçado toda hora pra chegar à procura
do país e chegou do time a chegar vamos
tirar distrai e constrói um discurso em
que anula o que o outro está a apontar
para ele é lindíssimo
é lindo é uma ofensa é uma brincadeira
isto interessa me imenso
como é que um jogo praticado inventado
não sei mas praticado por crianças têm
tantos conteúdos das diferenças sociais
políticas e religiosas
os cidadãos saem desapareceu das antigas
o savimbi desapareceu das filhas mesmo
tempo sabe o bem dos postes não sei o
quê
ou seja a xingava vivo do momento atual
vai se atualizando e as crianças num
jogo que aparentemente por 102 crianças
não precisa ser sério a onda que vão
buscar as religiosas do dna agora aqui
não tem acompanhado nos últimos anos mas
dessa vez chega com o chinês deve haver
este gás com uma madura mas não fez isso
chineses aqui de certeza não é certeza
não era uma festa religiosa mas digo
várias componentes étnicas é evidente já
vão ouvir daqui a bocado se abalar gênio
se eram seu cast é do sul rússia do
norte porque a criança tem a noção de
que há uma ofensa que pode acontecer por
essa via mas quem é que disse é uma
criança de sete anos que ele pode
ofender uma pessoa chamando falando da
origem étnica de uma pessoa e por que
que é uma ofensa à origem étnica de uma
pessoa é a performance do modo geral
porque este guia é uma performance não
interessa seja a venda deve chegar assim
também tem trechos que é a do meio da fé
resulta não resulta vamos ver se é do pt
eu gosto da discórdia
achei que era tudo mata boi quando o pai
do nervoso amarrar biquíni de bacon
papel do pai matou com a súmula por
cabeçada melhor e conseguiu descobrir os
hábitos de consumo total menos o pago
com suspensões
estava tudo pegando o jorge vai de lhe
roubar nada manda pra fazer parte quando
wang não vai mandar a campo nesta
partida que batendo perna quando o jogo
já acabou
button é a prova d'água do panamá roupa
do pai ficar mal estar foi um longo
tempo tem planos de construir um quarto
e uma sala do dubai que não condena do
estádio vai perguntar de maneira seja de
managing tocou com precisão absoluta não
canta dança toma conta de você
logo uma visita do pai quando foi quando
o time teve na baba nasceu para o
convidar para jogar mais tranquilo
pergunta se não canta nada não tem mix
não estou entendendo como ele chegou em
estado de espera no entanto a partilha
campo musical do país ou barba como a
quetamina também se fosse um novo bico
sapo morreu tombada tirou pedro no chão
falhou para o tempo da guerra se
esconderam na sombra de coco na tua casa
tem parabólica de papel ea pantanal do
homem que trabalhava com o pai passou
passou
em 1940 o grupo tocou à esquerda de
frango da tua mente ilosa nome é de dia
do homem
méxico 11 30 segundo o pai ele já e do
óbito
você foge que dão essa dica você chan
foi hoje pai chorar lá atrás só chora
que também é dj do óbito bom
em resumo só queria dizer uma coisa é a
coisa que mais me impressiona mais me
chamou a atenção além desses aspectos
que são sociológicos da construção do
discurso mas eu não tenho aqui tempo
abordar tudo isso é o papel da
imaginação
nós não podemos negar nem as crianças
nem os adultos o papel ea importância da
imaginação não é de vez em quando não em
ler um livro e ver um filme
a imaginação está presente nos nossos
dias para mim é importante que esteja
presente
vemos isso na rua vemos todos os dias
pela palavra nós angolanos temos uma
relação de imaginação com a palavra mas
eu acho que é muito importante que nunca
negamos as crianças mas não esquecemos
de nós do papel da imaginação na nossa
vida
muito obrigado